mi chiamo marina e credo nell'amore o
dieci anni sono caruccia e mi piace
tanto la ricci stima che il di candy a
scuola sono sempre tutta aggiustata
intanto però ricreazione am e sporco il
grembiule perché a scuola mia le
pizzette sono sempre estremamente
farcite allora la bidella gina me dice
bel ante preoccupare tanto poi se la va
la pizzetta in quanto tale st carica di
marciume devi solo star della bugia
mi chiamo marina e credo nell'amore ho
16 anni ea una festa ho conosciuto uno
che è un incrocio tra simon le bon e
l'operaio che ha fatto da contro sabetta
casa mia io sono più alta di lui e me
piace un sacco
mi chiamo marina e credo nell'amore con
giorgio alla fine ci siamo fidanzati
mamma mia quanto è bella io sono meglio
è però lo so quel suo carattere
introverso col suo modo di fare mi piace
mi chiamo marina e credo nell'amore chi
stare sposarlo un movente casco da la7
spiega piccolo vedevo quei film
americani con quelle belle storie
d'amore
[Musica]
sì mi sento proprio giulia roberz il mio
abito bianco con velo le fedi con i
nostri nomi
il viaggio di nozze mi chiamo marina e
credo nell'amore però la vita di coppia
immaginiamo un po meglio insomma cioè
lungo vuole bene per carità sempre più
geloso
quando mi arriva un messaggio mi strappa
il telefono dalle mani per vedere chi è
per carità e se ciò vuol dire che ci
tiene è ea me questo può solo far
piacere
lo so ho troppo
mi chiamo marina e credo nell'amore
l'altra sera ho fatto tardi lavoro è
ripreso tornando a casa del 9
già citata incazzato nero non ci credo
che mi fossi trattenuta lavoro che sarà
che fossi stata con altri
allora appena aperto la porta a terra
concerto nei trattori tanto ci ha fatto
male
però è fatto così lui caratteri sugo
stava pure un po nervoso e poi è stato
anche un po colpa mia quindi alla fine
mi ha chiesto scusa mi ha portato un
basso de rose grossa così e mi ha
promesso che non riesce occhio certo con
quelle ma non è ogni volta son dolori
io comunque lavoro hanno lasciato così
non si dispiace
mi chiamo marino
marito mi mette le mani addosso
se mi trucco troppo un ceffone se n'è
visto bene un ceffone che se lo faccio
per lui la mattina spero sempre che il
museo sveglia storto perché sono stato
lui
non me l'ero immaginato così
durante l'ennesima scenata giorgio mi ha
preso a calci buttato per terra e
l'ultima cosa che mi ricordo era che in
mano aveva un coltello il resto con lo
lascia immagino
mi chiamo marino ho 25 anni
vediamo per sempre perché sono morte
ora sto bene non sono soli
sono tantissime quassù le ragazze che
hanno fatto la mia stessa fine siamo
tantissimi però però stiamo bene perché
qua non si tratta l'unica non ci
trattavano un azzurro mi chiamo marina e
credo nell'amore lo vero quello che non
ti fa star male
quello che non decide quello che non
potrò provare di più
[Musica]
io forse ho sbagliato a sognare candy
candy e julia roberts è uno sbagliato
quel giorno ad andarmene via non è colpa
mia non è colpa mia
[Musica]
mi chiamo marino e credo nell'amore